tensión y cruce de acusaciones en Suiza
la sede del Consejo de derechos humanos
de Naciones Unidas en Ginebra fue este
jueves escenario de la división entre
los países occidentales e Irán en una
sesión de emergencia lo representantes
de los países miembros aprobaron crear
una investigación sobre el deterioro de
los derechos humanos
de la fuerza Debe llegar a su fin
Dios los viejos métodos y la mentalidad
de fortaleza de quienes ejercen el poder
Simplemente no funcionan de hecho solo
agravan la situación ahora Estamos en
una plena crisis de Derechos Humanos
unos 50 países encabezados por Alemania
e Islandia presentaron una moción ante
el organismo internacional para
investigar los presuntos abusos del
gobierno revolucionario islámico iraní
contra los manifestantes quienes llevan
más de dos meses en las calles en
protesta por la muerte bajo custodia
policial de la joven maxam mini quien
antes fue detenida por la policía de la
moral por llevar mal puesto el hillab
la República islámica de Irán lamenta
profundamente que el consejo de Derechos
Humanos se ha abusado una vez más por
algunos estados arrogantes para
antagonizar a un estado miembro soberano
de la ONU está totalmente comprometida
con su obligación de promover y proteger
los Derechos Humanos reducir la causa
común de los Derechos Humanos a una
herramienta con fines políticos
un grupo específico de países
occidentales es espantoso y vergonzoso
según la ONU la situación en el país es
crítica y el endurecimiento de la
respuesta de las autoridades ha causado
más de 300 muertes en los últimos dos
meses y dejaría alrededor de 14.000
arrestados todo ello mientras Teherán
acusa a sus enemigos extranjeros de
orquestar unas protestas que han calado
en todos los estratos sociales y suponen
el desafío más grande para el régimen
desde la revolución de 1979